mark Gasper is a former defense lobbyist
who's now Secretary of Defense
Esper was not elected to that position
obviously he was appointed to it by the
president who was himself elected that's
the chain of command and democracy
always voters choose their
representatives those representatives
choose their staff but all power flows
from the public who vote in elections
from you me and the rest of us when
cabinet officials ignore the
instructions of elected leaders they are
ignoring voters and attacking democracy
in case of the military it's especially
dangerous our armed services are
controlled by the president who was
elected in many countries that's not the
case when politicians in those places do
something the military doesn't like the
general stage of coup or they threaten
one places like that invariably are
violent and chronically unstable we're
not at all like that here and we don't
want to be we can give our nuclear
weapons to the military on the promise
that we're essentially in charge of when
they use them because we elect
presidents who make that call probably
knew all that it's basic civics or it
was until Donald Trump got elected
recently the president suggested that he
might invoke the insurrection Act that
would allow him to use American troops
to quell the riots in our cities
now that's his call you can agree with
it or not but he's the president it's up
to him it is not up to Mark Esper if
Mark espera doesn't like it he can
resign and he can vote against Donald
Trump in the fall he may do that anyway
but that's his option what espera can't
do what we cannot let him do if we care
about democracy is to subvert the order
of the president he works for no matter
who the president is
and yet yesterday mark espera appeared
to do exactly that
he gave a press conference in which he
announced that he opposes using troops
to bring order to the country American
troops in Syria and Afghanistan are
absolutely necessary we can't pull them
out it's immoral but we can't use
Americans to protect America that's mark
espers position apparently Esper said
this at the urging of active duty
generals at the Pentagon now once again
it doesn't matter
whether you agree with their position
this kind of behavior is a grave threat
to all of us and to our constitutional
system and that system is teetering
tonight we hate even to say that out
loud but it's true it is some in
Washington would like to see the system
collapse completely congressman Ruben
Gallego for example just sent a letter
to general mark Milley he's the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff telling him
to defy the elected president if ordered
to suppress the riots this is insanity
and it can't lead anywhere good
for 230 years we have been the
beneficiaries of civilian control of the
military it's one of the main reasons
this country has always been stable but
when the military becomes an independent
political force it's over
democracy dies we've resisted that many
times just before the Second World War
for example FDR ordered his generals to
help Joseph Stalin and lend-lease
they didn't want to do that they hated
Stalin and for good reason they
understood the mortal threat of
communism but they were told to do it
and they did it because that's our
system it's democracy that system has
worked very well for a long time
in fact it's why we revere our military
because we can we they're not part of
our political system their only job is
to protect the country and they do but
if people like Mark Esper continue on
this path we will not like our military
at all we will be very afraid of them
and we don't want to be Brian Dean
Wright is a Democrat he's a former CIA
officer we're happy to have him join us
tonight Brian thanks so much for coming
on now I'm not gonna ask you what you
think of the president's idea to invoke
the insurrection act to put troops on
the streets I want to ask instead about
the chain of command you served in
government can bureaucrats decide
unilaterally to make policy well that's
what we've seen the past three years
isn't it Brennan clapper Comey that all
that's now coming out that's not a new
phenomenon of course it's a horrifying
one but it's not new but what we have
here I think more specifically is a
Secretary of Defense who doesn't get it
all right right now let's just
to the chase sucker this country is on
fire
we are facing an insurrection by people
that we don't quite understand who they
are but by all indications they are
violent leftist thugs and what secretary
Esper doesn't quite seem to get either
is that the nation is panicking 71% of
us want the National Guard in our cities
tonight 58% of us want the military in
our cities tonight
all right the people are panicking the
country is on fire
now who is attacking us mr. Esper should
know this
it's an Tifa Department of Justice and
YPD others are saying this very clearly
these are people by the way that we face
back in the 1960s and 70s and early 80s
these were people who were far leftist
Marx letting you know folks who embraced
that ideology they allied with Black
Panther movements and it took many years
to finally put it down very dangerous
and now this same group who was allied
by the way with the democratic
socialists we're talking to Bernie Bros
and mr. Cosmo Cortez they're back
they're back with fire bombs they're
backed with bricks and our suburbs and
our downtown's that's something that mr.
Esper clearly doesn't understand and
then finally we have a media that is
feeding this flame this horrific fire
this seditious nnessee have brought this
up many times including tonight let me
read a a headline from Slate Magazine
just yesterday said the following
peaceful protests are important tool but
so is violence so now we have a media
filling the Airways full of this crap
yeah put it all together and the piece
that you mentioned no more police
because we're gonna defund those folks
we can't put forward the National Guard
because that would be escalation so now
we take off the military from the table
what does that leave Tucker let me tell
you what it leaves vigilante justice
that's it's you and me and everybody
watching this program arming ourselves
is that how we run a republic no sir it
is not and you cannot want a country
that goes there and that is precisely
where the nation is headed and we need
for all of our leadership to understand
that and if secretary Esper doesn't get
it
doesn't understand that the oath is to
protect ourselves from threats both
foreign and domestic
by God get the hell out of the Pentagon
and let somebody lead who gets it
because that is the oath that he took
that I took and it the people of this
country demand of our leadership in this
moment because we are on fire someone do
something about it I couldn't agree more
that's it that's inspiring Brian I
appreciate it and you just have to
wonder why people are encouraging this
you really should meditate on that I
think I have been wrecked my day Brian
great to see you thank you